hier le président de la république
emmanuel macron donné une interview au
magazine le parisien pendant un peu plus
de deux heures il a répondu aux
questions de sept lecteurs habitués du
journal écologie europe présidentielle
le chef de l'état n'a éludé aucun sujet
et surtout pas le thème de la
vaccination sur lequel il a été
intraitable les non-vaccinés j'ai très
envie de les emmerder et donc on va
continuer de le faire jusqu'au bout
alors comment se sont déroulées les
coulisses de cette interview pourquoi
cette phrase fait-elle tant polémique
emmanuel macron avait-il prépa les
questions
ce soir olivier baumont doit reporter
politique due par l'état est avec nous
en exclusivité pour tout nous dire de
cet entretien dont tout le monde parle
aujourd'hui
merci
à voir avec aujourd'hui merci je suis
pas tout seul et la voix organise c'est
une chose c'est bien sûr bravo à toute
la rédaction du service police bien su
arésiens bravo vermont c'est vrai qu'ils
sont très bons a toujours un nathalie
non nous a quittés les parrains au point
je l'adoré aussi voilà bon baladeur
toujours pas très bien voilà d'or au
point on l'adoré au parisien on
l'adorait au point si elle nous regarde
olivier baumont grand reporter politique
donc qui a fait cette interview on à
philippe moureaux chevrolet qu'on aime
beaucoup dans l'émission spécialiste en
communication politique qui va nous dire
aussi dit voilà on a plein de questions
qu'on se pose sur cette interview
comment vous avez décroché déjà cette
interview moi j'étais je me suis dit là
franchement je n'ai pas cru parce que
moi c'est indépendant l'émission mais en
fait je vous dit tout je ne raconte moi
je peux pas vous dire qui mais c'est en
fait c'est là bas c'est un ministre qui
m'a envoyé l'interview du président
téléphone et donc des bûchers c'est une
vanne est en fait je vois la déclaration
suite à une panne et en fait c'était
vrai d'ailleurs j'ai dit hier c'était
toi tu savais pas que c'est dans le
parisien sait comment ça s'est passé
c'est bon qu'il avait contacté oui ça
remonte à au mois d'octobre où on a
sollicité l'elysée pour avoir une
interview du président de la république
début janvier l'idée étant initialement
de parler avec le président des
questions européennes puisque depuis
saint janvier la france tient la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
le format n'était pas arrêtée quand on a
fait cette proposition à dire l'elysée
nous a dit qu'est ce que vous nous
proposez une tenue classique ou autre
chose et c'est vrai que très
naturellement on s'est orienté sur un
format qui as est très connu et qui est
très identifiée au parisien qu'il existe
une phase de l'extérieur effet c'est
fabuleux ben voilà exactement vous avez
fait cyril et donc du faso lecteurs où
on voulait me est ce que parce que
manger dans une salle oui avec genre
voilà une petite salle de réunion au
fort mal gommer salle de réunion jour là
le cheminot pas rien d'une salle de
réunion avec plein de deux doivent de
lecteurs du parisien est ce que vous
avez fait pareil pour lui où il y avait
un protocole pas là ça s'est passé à
l'elysée adacore à l'elysée voilà un
vrai bien et donc pour terminer par
rapport à votre question précédente
il s'est passé on a eu plusieurs
plusieurs entretiens rencontres et
échanges téléphoniques avec les
conseillers du président de la
république est très vite donc on
s'orientait sur ce ils ont dit
effectivement ça peut être un bon format
de faire cette rencontre avec le
président est parée de l'europe au
quotidien l'europe pour les français
qu'est ce que 0 contre l'inter
exactement c'était les trois-quarts de
l'interview d'après vous parlez bien à
la vue des donc on a l'accord pour la
faire courte on a l'accord de l'elysée
le 18 décembre il a branle bas de combat
effectivement depuis son arrivée à la
veille des vacances de noël il faut
composer sur yann l
comment se compose un panel c'est très
simple un au parisien on a un fichier de
lecteurs qui peuvent s'inscrire
spontanément voilà et à chaque fois
qu'on le pari d'organiser un panel ça
peut être avec un invité politique une
personnalité des médias ou des arts et
des spectacles ou un sportif
effectivement on sollicite des lecteurs
est ce que ça vous intéresserait de
rencontrer en l'occurrence c'était un
omnium avait beaucoup de demandes et là
comme s'était chef de l'état comme pour
les prédécesseurs avec françois hollande
et nicolas sarkozy l'entretien s'est
passé au palais de l'elysée assure alors
donc le président vous vous l'avez fait
donc cette idée vous l'avez faite le 18
décembre non l'état russe a fait hier en
fait il y en a eu l'accord le 18
décembre et l'interview était fait
l'accord mis hier matin elle a commencé
à 11h le l'interview en tant que telle
la préparation leur infinie bell et
telus a duré quasiment deux heures 2
heures 5 là le micam s'est terminée et
après il ya un moment un peu plus
convivial où il ya eu déjà là la séance
photo sur le perron c'est un des
panélistes et chef de l'état et puis
après ils ont voulu faire quelques ses
filles avec lui c'est normal pour les
étés souvenirs étaient heureux de qu'est
ce qu'ils ont dit les lecteurs du
président oui il a demandé en trouver
tant il est content vous c'est très
juste la phrase d'un kiki tout de suite
après le l'entretien qui est venu voir
il m'a dit je ne pense pas que c'était
un électeur d'emmanuel mâcon pour le
coup parce qu'il me dit c'est parce
qu'alain je crois qu'ils me dit oui moi
je suis pas forcément d'accord avec tout
ce qu'il dit on peut ne pas l'aimer mais
en tout cas là sur les deux heures en
tout cas les à celui-ci les a séduit
parce que on n'a pas tout retranscrit en
a pas tout public doit se faire du mal
aux heures d'interviews s'est énormément
de deux signes nokia eu des questions ce
que les vise à vérifier les profils ou
pas du tout pas du tout nous on compose
un rationnel et vous avez vous leur avez
donné les questions avant a jamais
jamais jamais quoi le mej le président a
découvert les questions oui les mêmes
nous a vraiment mais nous ça se passe
comment incroyable avant on convie les
panélistes autour d'une grande table on
a eu les leurs questions la veille ou 48
heures avant et nous en fait pendant
deux heures déjà les panélistes
apprennent à se connaître
et nous on met deux on est là nous les
journalistes dans ce travail de
préparation en amont on est là pour
mettre un peu de l'ordre dans leurs
questions c'est ça il ya des quelques
nations va pas retenir parce qu elles
sont hors de propos à son bord quatre
quoi que ce soit et puis voilà l'idée de
l'agression européennes et après on a
fait qu'on a on a séquencé
question sécurité questions sanitaires
évidemment question l'éducation et puis
la campagne politique et après bout de
deux heures on a eu une trame de
question et après on leur dit bon bah
voilà
à 10h30 on a changé de pièces on arrive
dans les salles et jardins d'hiver et on
leur dit à chaque fois enfin tout pour
tous les panélistes improvisé ce moment
là vous avez en leur facturant vous avez
le chef de l'état devant vous donc
n'hésitez pas à le relancer à
l'interpeller faites vous plaisir parce
que vous êtes et comme des privilégiés
dans ces moments là et donc voilà il ya
près dans ce moment là nous on s'efface
totalement ils ont l'ordre des questions
et puis après ça déroule pendant deux
heures alors est-ce qu'il a demandé à
relire l'interview le président de la
république alors il ya un exercice ce
qui est habituel que pas nouveau un qui
annule le sud la relecture de courtoisie
pourquoi parce que dans cette interview
je voulais dit juste avant grosso modo
quand la décrypter on devait avoir entre
40 et 45 mille signes lors on a six
pages d'un journal pour 20 10 ça fait
environ un peu plus de ça fait
vingt-cinq mille signes bien sûr on n'a
pas tout garder il ya des questions
qu'on a enlevé notamment il y avait une
j'ai en mémoire sur la pac ou la f1 une
réponse tunnel c'était hyper technique
on suivait pas on aurait décroché donc
on a enlevé quelques questions dont on a
envoyé la version finale que nous on a
choisi de garder donc ceci est un genre
éditorial l'elysée on a eu connaissance
et voilà est à présent publié la version
qu'on leur a envoyé mi ya eu aucune
reculeau une phrase enlevé aucun mot de
d'amendé ni de rien du tout alors
justement il ya une phrase qui est sorti
une phrase kafka qui a fait parler tout
le monde d'hier sur les réseaux sociaux
c'était un truc de fou il a dit alors
c'est une infirmière donc lhi sa belle
infirmière qui lui parle l'aider non
vaccinés qui occupent le site 85% des
réanimations qui du coup sont
responsables selon elles des reports
d'opérations de cancer par exemple la
question que le poser isabelle elle
était mine de rien c'est vrai qu'elle
voulait un peu piqué le le président eh
bien voilà nous on galère à cause et non
vaccinés pour qu'elles étaient un peu
orienté ses vraies questions de
l'infirmière et et lui donc a eu cette
phrase voilà il dit alors je vous hais
ce que vous venez de dire c'est le
meilleur argument démocratie le pire
ennemi c'est le mensonge et la bêtise
nous mettons une pression sur les non
vaccinés en limitant pour eux autant que
possible l'accès aux activités de la vie
sociale d'ailleurs la quasi totalité des
gens plus de 90% déry c'est une toute
petite minorité réfractaires comme en
celle là comme on la réduit ont l'art et
du pardon de le dire comme ça en emmerde
encore davantage je ne suis pas pour
emmerder les français je peste toute la
journée contre l'administration quand
elle débloque et bien là les non
vaccinés j'ai très envie de les emmerder
on va continuer à le faire jusqu'au bout
c'est ça la stratégie alors c'est cette
phrase qui ressortit partout quand vous
avez publié l'interview et quand vous
avez envoyé cette interview chef de
l'état est ce que vous êtes dit ça il va
me l'enlever ou pas du tout déjà nous
alors le dispositif était particulier
parce que quand il a pris le protocole
sanitaire d'ordinaire un face aux
lecteurs vous en avez fait cyril une
grande table ovale la ronde et puis donc
là il ya une interaction qui se fait
quand même plus facilement que là où on
était contraint par des ddd certain
nombre d'espèces ont surfé rentable et
donc nous les journalistes on était cinq
journalistes du service politique quand
il a prononcé cette phrase nous on s'est
regardés a bien sûr que l'on se dise où
la famille et moi je me serais dit il va
dire il va nous lancer à sa part contre
isabelle est il là les autres panélistes
n'ont pas réagi de cet âge
est effectivement
l'elysée n'a pas tiqué sur cette phrase
et je pense même à l'heure où on se
parle ils sont pas mécontents de ce
qu'ils ont fait